hi in this lecture i'm going to talk
about sarcastic gradient descent
so recall grading ascent which was the
optimization
algorithm that we decided on for
optimizing all our training losses for
classification and regression
so recall that the training loss is an
average
over all the examples in the training
set
of the per example losses
so graded descent
works as follows
we're going to initialize the weight
vector to 0 and then we're going to
repeat t times
and do the following update
we're going to take
the old wave vector and subtract out the
step size times the gradient over the
training loss
and now this looks very simple but if
you unpack
what this gradient is it's actually an
average over the gradients of the per
example losses
so now imagine you have a data set with
a million examples computing the single
gradient is going to include involve
looping over all million examples just
to get a single update
and then you take a step
and then you have to do it all over
again
so this is why gradient descent is slow
because it requires going through all
the training examples just to make one
update
so what can we do about this
so the answer is stochastic gradient
descent
so here is the same training loss
function and stochastic gradient set is
going to work as follows so we
initialize the weight vectors to zero
and then we iterate t times
and now
on each
epoch we're going to
loop
over
the trainings examples and then perform
an update
on
the individual losses
okay so here
instead of
going through the training set
and performing one
update
we're going to go through the training
set and after each example we're going
to perform an update
and this is going to be a lot faster in
terms of
having the number of updates be large
of course there is a trade-off because
each update itself is not going to be as
high quality because it's only consists
of one example as opposed to all of the
examples
and that's it for stochastic gradient
descent i want to talk about one small
note
which is the step size
so recall the update is
includes a step size which determines
how
far in the direction of the gradient or
away from the gradient do you want to
move
okay so what should ada be and in
general there's not really a one
satisfying answer to this and it's
usually a hyper parameter that has to be
tuned via trial and error but here's
some general guidance here so the step
size has to be greater or equal to zero
and if it is small
that means you're taking little little
steps but that means your algorithm is
going to be more stable and less likely
to bounce around
and as you increase ada larger and
larger
then you're taking more aggressive steps
so you can move faster
but perhaps at the risk of being a bit
more unstable
so two typical strategies for setting
the step size one is using just a
constant step size
we've used so far a equals 0.1 kind of
arbitrary number
um or you can do a decreasing step size
rate where ada is one over
the number of updates
that you've made
and the intuition here is that in the
beginning
you're far away from the optimum so
you're going to move quickly you want to
move quickly but as soon as you start
getting closer although you want to slow
down
so now let us
explore stochastic gradient descent um
in python i'm going to code it up and uh
see
you know what happens
okay
so remember last time we degraded
descent so i'm going to
copy this code over
descent hinge
uh sorry i just sent stochastic gradient
descent
um and
what we're going to do is modify this
code to make it uh do staccato screen
descent
okay so just recall last time we set up
some training examples um we define the
loss function and then we have this
generic optimization algorithm
so now to really tell the difference
between gradient descent and category
and descent i'm going to make a larger
data set and i'm going to do it in a way
so that it's large but it's structured
so we know what the right answer is
because otherwise how can we verify that
it did the right thing
to do this uh this is kind of a just a
general trick is that you kind of
generate synthetic data from kind of a
ground truth and then you try to recover
that ground truth so suppose we had some
true way vector
um this is our secret code which is
unknown to the learning algorithm but we
hope that learning algorithm will
recover this
and then we're going to define a
function called generate which
uses this true w to generate an example
so
here i'm going to generate x
and i'm going to just sample randomly um
a five-dimensional uh weight vector
oh sorry uh a
input point
and then i'm going to set y
to be
true w dot x
so true
the examples i'm going to generate are
generated from the true ray vector and
then i'm just going to add some
noise
okay and then i'm going to
set the training examples to be just
generate
uh for
let's say
one let's do one million examples that's
a lot of examples
all right
so let's see what this data looks like
so i'm going to print out x and y
and just to see what is coming out
oops um i had a typo here
okay so here is the data set that we are
going to train on
so example x is a five
vector and the output is a scalar so
there's a lot of examples here
okay
all right so i need to update the
feature vector um
to be just x
identity and here i'm going to the
initial way vector has to match the
dimensionality of the of the true wave
vector
and then everything else the training
loss and gradient are i'm going to leave
along okay
so now let's uh
uncomment this line
and let's run gradient descent let's see
what happens here
okay so it's going to
generate the data and now
to compute a single gradient it has to
enumerate
over 1 million examples
so this is going to be quite slow i'll
finish the first epoch
and
it has some some values
so
and then the second epoch
and it seems like it's making some
progress
remember we want to see if this can hit
one two three four five
um the loss is going down
which is good and it seems like it's
moving in the right direction but um
it's it's pretty slow and i'm just going
to stop it there because i don't want to
wait forever
okay so now let's do sarcastic gradient
descent
so
first i need to
change the interface because gradient
descent only had access to f and the
gradient of f
and now stochastic gradient descent
needs to access individual losses
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
define a stochastic
or actually i'll just call this the loss
of w
i'm going to
use i
here to denote
an index into one of these terms in the
sum
so what the loss is going to be
is
it's just going to be one
of these
terms
and the term i'm going to select out is
just the i
data point
okay
and similarly
the the gradient
of the loss
is
going to be just
uh the gradient
but for
the ith
data point
and this also takes in the index i
so now if i feed in i for various values
i can access the loss and the gradient
of that loss function for any given
point vector
all right so
so now let's go over to the optimization
algorithm and let me do stochastic
gradient descent
okay so i'm going to call this
stochastic
gradient descent
and i'm going to call this just to
distinguish things i'm going to use
lowercase f
for like individual components of the
objective function
okay so i'm going to initialize the
weight vector
i'm going to
use a different step size here just for
fun
um i'm going to initialize with one
um
actually let me do this instead
i'm going to set the step size to be 1
over the square root of number of
updates
and each time i do an update
i'm going to
[Music]
increase the number of updates so
actually let me do it in this order
okay so number of updates is starts at
zero
um and then
uh remembering sarcastic gradient
descent
i'm going to
loop over
um the number
of components of
the objective function
so 1
0 to m minus 1.
so another thing i'm going to have to
pass in
is the number of components
that i'm going to use to index into f
and so now this is f of w i gradient f
of w i
and then i'm going to move everything
inward
okay
so
now to call this function
i'm going to run stochastic gradient
descent
and with just the loss
and
the the gradient of the loss
um i'm going to pass an n which is a
number of
training examples and an initial weight
vector
okay so let's just review what's going
on here so sarcastic gradient descent
takes a function which can access
individual components of the objective
it initializes the weights and then
uh iterates
some number of times and in each epoch
it's going to
in loop over all the examples compute
the value compute the gradient
and then
it's going to
do a gradient update
and here i'm using the step size which
is one over the number of updates that
i've made so far
okay so let's see
um sarcastic gradient descent in action
now
uh i have two returns here so that is a
syntax error let me fix that
um so now it's going through one million
examples oh i need to
import math as well
um
so it's going to loop over 1 million
examples but each example it's going to
perform an update
and so when it prints out it's going to
have already taken 1 million steps
of stochastic radiant descent
and look what happened here
so after the first step it's already
quite close to one two three four five
and the objective
uh
i guess the function value doesn't
really mean as much because it's only of
an individual point but you can see that
the
weight vector is converging you know
quite nicely
and this shows that stochastic gradient
descent
just even sometimes with one passable
training data can get
uh much closer to the optimum than if
you were to do
um many many rounds of gradient descent
okay so that was
a sarcastic radiant descent in python
so let's summarize here
so we want to optimize this training
loss which is an average over the per
example losses
and we looked at gradient descent
which takes a step
on the gradient of the training loss
and we also looked at stochastic
gradient descent which picked up
individual examples and updated
on computing after computing the
gradient of individual examples
and now we on this example we've shown
that sarcastic gradient descent wins and
the key idea behind stochastic updates
is that it's not about quality it's
about quantity
so maybe not a general life lesson
but it seems like in this case it is
more wise to keep in mind what you're
trying to do which is optimize this
objective
rather than compute
the gradient which is only a means to an
end
okay so that concludes the module on
stochastic gradient design thanks for
listening